you
hey youtubers it's Charlie so if you
guys didn't know this is a teaser for a
giant trailer that is coming tomorrow
there is a brand new Captain America
Civil War right around the corner if the
game of thrones trailer yesterday didn't
wake you guys up this should do the
trick
united we stand divided we fall so this
is just the initial lineup I don't know
if spider-man is gonna be in the big
IMAX sequence he might come after that
but the writers did explain what their
big they call it the splash page scene
it's a 15 minute battle scene shot with
IMAX cameras and as you probably guessed
from the other teasers they dropped it
takes place on this airport tarmac the
reason they call it a 15 minute splash
page scene is because the writers said
that is children as we all used to do
when brick-and-mortar comic book stores
were the only way to get comic books is
you would go in and you would open up
the splash page like the two-page spread
of some giant comic book battle and just
try and count all the different
characters that were in the scene
sometimes there be hundreds probably the
most famous plasticine is this Gimli
x-men number one splash page but you get
the idea you just sit there for 15
minutes not buying the comic getting
yelled at by the store owner because
you're just trying to count all the
characters that's actually a good
question let me know in the comments
have you ever been chased out of a comic
book store when you're a kid or maybe
even recently because you were just
opening and trying to read comics
without buying them most of my comics I
get on comiXology now I don't buy a lot
of paper comics anymore unless it's
something that's really special like a
collected edition but I think the last
big series that I actually tried to just
like sit in the comic book store and
read before I actually bought it was
Marvel's first civil war which actually
wasn't too long ago I mean it's like
2006 2007 so it's about 10 years ago but
they have confirmed that this is gonna
be the longest Marvel movie to date it's
still not quite as long as Batman vs
Superman it's just a couple minutes shy
of two and a half hours Batman V
Superman is right at about two and a
half hours so they're about the same
length you have to keep in mind there's
gonna be like 10 minutes of credits
after each of these movies so really
like whatever the runtime is subtract 10
minutes from that for the actual movie
and they did confirm that there is no
Thanos in the movie they said there was
just way too much stuff going on for
spaceman to make an appearance
they called him spaceman they and the
producers felt like creepy spaceman
would completely overshadow anything
that was going on in the movie
the minute he shows up in a scene he's
all you can think about so whatever was
going on with cap Iron Man and Bucky
would just get shoved to the side if
Thanos ever showed up so creepy spaceman
infinity gems going to be happening soon
and they did speaking of infinity gems
Elizabeth Olsen who plays Scarlet Witch
was talking about her character
envisions relationship she says that
there is a connection there they're on
different teams she's team cap he's team
Iron Man but because both of their
powers flow from the mind gem there is a
connection you do have to remember
though that they're not doing the exact
comic book Civil War story there is a
Stanford incident but it's not quite the
same thing they're not doing Inhumans
and they're not gonna be any agents of
shield people in the movie there will be
Captain America Civil War stuff
happening on agents of shield so the
crossover will mostly take place on the
TV show it didn't really say which
episode that's going to be though but I
am gonna post my agents of shield video
later today
Ward is confirmed to be playing the hive
character from the secret warriors
storyline in the comics if you're
familiar with that I'm really curious to
see if after agents of shield this
season hive inhabits another body and we
get Madame Hydra the way the TV show is
using the hive characters a little bit
different than it was used in the comics
the TV show version is a little more
powerful so be sure to watch agents of
shield this season there's gonna be
crazy Inhumans they just introduced a
couple new characters but I'll explain
that during my agents of shield video
later tonight so be sure to subscribe
for new Captain America civil war
trailer tomorrow a new agents of shield
why you guys wait for me to post that
video if you haven't seen it five
billion times you can click here for the
Game of Thrones red band trailer and you
can click here for all my Captain
America Civil War videos thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight
you